good evening everybody
um and welcome to the performance
governance and audit committee meeting
on Thursday the 21st of July 2022 my
name is councilor Wendy stamp and I'm
the chairman of this committee members
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are given your
consent to being recorded join each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak I will then invite you
at the appropriate time please note that
the YouTube live stream sound recording
is dependent on the correct use of
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
again when finished
please reference a page and paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
moving on to agenda item 2 members
apologies for absence may I have
apologies for absence please Berner
yes chairman received apologies for
absence from cancer schemes thank you
and I'd like to say that obviously Mr
Dodson is absent as well at the moment
moving on agenda item three it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of June 2022
found on pages 5 to 14 are approved as a
true and accurate record ISO move do I
have a second for this motion
um councilor Fleming
members
do we all agree by ascent
thank you
Declarations of Interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests or
the registerable yeah they've said the
right interest and non-registerable
interests relating to items of business
and on the agenda have a regard to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
members
councilor Fleming
thank you chair of registerable Interest
as a member of Essex County Council any
item on the agenda that is relevant
thank you
and I also will have the same notable
interest as a member of Essex County
Council but I don't see anything on the
agenda tonight public participation I
can advise that we've not received any
submissions from members of the public
but moving on to a gender item six
found on pages 15 and 16. to consider
the report of the director of resources
and the report of the internal auditor
from a to G on the agenda I'm going to
hand over to Mr Rubin and please to
present the reports thank you
thank you very much and good evening
everyone
um because there are so many reports to
present I'm I'm proposing doing this in
three different
um chunks if that's okay so
um items A and B together is the first
part
um I'll take any questions at that point
or um and then item c d and e
um as the second part and then finally
items f and g so
um if that's acceptable chairman I'll
I'll move on to items A and B that's
exceptional to me um members are you
agreed
thank you Mr Reuben okay so um the
progress report uh is fairly
straightforward we've got
um here today two reports from our from
2122 program and two uh for the 22-23 we
have two further reports just to finish
off the
2021-22 year which are in draft so
that's contract management and
commercialization so we're just
finalizing management responses on those
on the follow-up on the whole progress
It's reasonable there are still some
areas that need to be followed up and
they include flood management and
safeguarding and those will be followed
up as part of new audits that we'll be
doing in 2022 23 and so we'll pick up
those as part of those audits on the
whole uh otherwise there's there's
pretty good progress particularly in
2122 recommendations
um but there is still a high priority
One outstanding on affordable housing
but as I say overall I think reasonable
progress so I'll stop at that point just
on items A and B if there are any
questions
yeah on the
page 29 the flood risk why is it still
over Joe
and if I go on to the other two
questions that I've got then you can
answer all the officers can answer them
all page 33 1.1 affordable housing can
we have an explanation why the due date
has been moved from April 22 to
September and can we be assured that
this kpi will be set up by then
um 1.2 again can we be assured that this
will be implemented by the end of next
week
and there is another one which is
management of property will this target
for September be met or will they be put
off again
um
Mr Rubens do you want to answer anything
I think that's mainly for offices I mean
I understand there's been resourcing
pressures in a number of areas but I
think it's for officers to answer
um Mr Gayla do you want oh sorry Mr
Holmes
yes so Mr Gill I can pick up the first
couple of items and I can pick up the um
the assets
um Point can I can I jump in first to
say about the affordable housing I think
we all know that we are working really
hard to achieve that and I think it's
not just a fault of I know Mr Gale is
responsible manager for it but I think
it's uh it's not just uh his yeah
responsibility we are working really
hard to try and address the affordable
homes issue Mr Gayla
so just in relation to the affordable
housing Target
um affordable 1.1 where it talks about
ongoing monitoring and delivery
um against the action plan of affordable
housing targets now this data is
actually collated
um so it's been done it's carried out by
an officer John swords but what is
happening is the data needs to be
further disseminated to CLT by the
balanced scorecard or shared with
members in the Strategic housing board
meeting there is an example of what the
data looks like on page 131 so that work
is happening once it turns up on the
balance scorecard I'll be able to report
this as complete it's more a case of the
data's always been collected it's just
the reporting upwards okay I'm quite
happy with that are you um cancer stilts
yeah
your next next question was to whom
I think that was again to Mr Geller
which was 1.2 which is can we be assured
that this date will be
um this will be implemented by the end
of next week which is what the date on
there is for yes so my apologies this
will slip slightly so just to explain
um the housing strategy is basically
still valid
um there were still many uh points in
there which uh you know a deliverable uh
what we need to do is basically just put
a report to the next SNR Community which
will be on the 15th of the 9th so that's
when hopefully it will be extended
um to give reassurance though the
policies sorry the strategy is still
active still live and it still forms the
basis of the service delivery so it's
not like it's not in place it is in
place it just needs extended just a bit
slow yes okay thank you
um and I think the thought the final one
was on management property was it can I
just say before anybody answers uh
councilor Hall's just joined us burner
can you make a note that councilor
holder joined us welcome
that's fine
um
thank you is it so yes management of
property um we've now linked this to the
new Asset Management working groups that
was on the agenda for discussion um
which is I think as late as yesterday in
terms of taking that forward there are
issues around resources and the level of
detail that we will need to put to this
process so officers will be looking at
the the detail on how we might take this
forward
um as part of that and obviously we'll
be reporting back through the asset
management working group on that
um I can't give you the definitive as
whether we will I don't think we will
have completed that work um it's quite a
large project by September 22 but I'd
hope we would have laid the foundation
so we know sort of time scale and what
what it is we can be doing to achieve
the outcome desired
okay thank you guys that's all right
councilor stilts and anybody else
members
oh yes councilor Fleming thank you chair
I think the um councilor stilts uh other
question was about flood risk yes I was
going to give Damian the
opportunity thank you
thank you so um there has been a fair
bit of work around flood risk in the
background
um you're right there isn't a flood risk
strategy in place there isn't the suds
in place specifically for Malden and
that's because
while we're you know we hold the risk
for flooding the actual partners that
deal with it as an action as the lead
agency uh the environment agency in
Essex County Council so we're very much
um have to link in with them so they
actually have those strategies and then
they're in place
um we are looking at trying to put some
more
um I wouldn't say resource but
additional support into that work stream
so hopefully more details will start
coming around shortly there is the flood
strategy master plan which details all
the works that are happening across the
district I'll arrange for that to be
distributed to all members so you can
see what he's actually uh on plan
um and there is uh uh the bones of a
modern light strategy just to give you
some guidance and context and hopefully
that will be shared as well soon
excellent thank you right
um Mr Rubens I must apologize I called
you Mr Rubin I missed your ass off so
please accept my apologies
um I think you can move on to
um c d and e yes thank you so um we're
on to um page 37 of the papers now
um so there's three uh reports I'll talk
to now so the first one is the workforce
management report where we're giving
substantial Assurance that's our highest
level of assurance on both the design
and effectiveness of controls and we
thought this was a very well managed
area and you know given how important it
is to the council is very positive
um so there's clearly been a lot of
focus around this area
um you're doing a lot of work around
hybrid working and formalizing plans
there
um staff are being consulted and their
views taken seriously so a lot of good
things there and we only came up with
one minor Improvement which is just in
terms of the strategy and expanding it
when it's revised to include areas like
staff empowerment and diversity and
inclusion so as I said a very positive
report there
if I move on to 6D that's the customer
relationship management uh report
um so that's
um
age 53 of your papers
um that's uh had a moderate Assurance
for both design and Effectiveness so
um you know the council has had issues
with its current uh customer
relationship management
um uh system thermostat
um and it's doing a lot of good work to
replace that with a new System Dynamics
365 so the current system has a number
of issues it includes quite a lot of
Staff time needs to be put in because of
duplication of input because it doesn't
Link in properly to the council's other
systems so um you know it's very
positive to see how that is is going
um that we came up with two points there
one is the need to have a benefits
realization document so that will set
out what benefits you expect to see from
the new system and then obviously it
helps us as Auditors or management to go
back and see whether those benefits have
actually happened in practice so it
wasn't done for firm step for a number
of reasons um but management committed
to do that for the new system and
secondly just making sure you have a
very a comprehensive log of issues
um for what's coming out of firm step
there are quite a few issues coming out
but we thought there needed to be more
detail about you know who raised the
issue What's the timing what sort of
priority and again that has been
accepted by management so
um you know we've got a good action plan
for that one
and then just finally in this block of
reports uh our annual opinion which we
give each year uh summarizes all of our
work that's on
um page 67 of your papers uh and we're
giving moderate Assurance overall that's
our second highest level it's the same
as we gave last year uh I think again uh
positive um you know the majority of uh
uh reports that we did came out
substantial Assurance on design on
Effectiveness they're more moderate than
substantial but we have no limited uh
opinions at all in the year and given
the sort of very challenging
circumstances that have continued over
the last year with covid and resource
constraints and so on I think that's
that again is a good performance so
there are some areas for improvement
we've talked about the follow-up and
just making sure all recommendations are
implemented when uh when it's been
agreed and that may be not just around
implementation but also maybe office has
been a bit more realistic about when
they can do things when we agree the
original report sometimes I think
perhaps they're a bit ambitious so just
making sure we've got realistic time
scales and that those are met in
practice but overall as I said a
positive report and our own performance
we've had good feedback on our work and
good quality assessments as well so
overall you know we think we're we're
doing okay but obviously always subject
to others opinions so I'll stop at that
point with that Block C D E and happy to
take any comments or questions members
oh oh
cancer Stevens
thank you chair
um my question is about the dash system
um throughout my whole year first year
of being a member I never heard of Dash
and suddenly everyone's talking about
Dash there's lots of mentions of Dash in
here
um I raised a dangerous structure
request about 10 days ago and after
three days I then raised fresh service
request because I hadn't heard anything
and I thought surely a dangerous
structure should be responded to
instantly and it turned out that it was
because of a dash problem that it hadn't
got through and eventually although I
had a dangerous structure record number
it was blank or something like that
I found that really really alarming and
I'd be interested to know if we have got
problems on going with Dash and what's
being done about those please thank you
Mr Holmes will you be able to take that
one I'm afraid I won't be able to take
it on this evening if Mr Leslie was it's
probably a technical matter though I've
not been made aware of so I apologies
nobody at uh online is there I can't see
any officer that will be able to address
thank you no we can take that away and
have a look I heard nothing reported
that there's ongoing issues um of course
there could well have been as you've
pointed out uh an issue at that
particular time I'm not aware of ongoing
issues but certainly look into that and
of course the report does pick up some
of the limitations of our current system
and the steps we're taking to address
that so um yeah I'll pick that up with
the team thank you
and anybody else
nope
do we eventually doing the last two yes
last block of reports so uh we're nearly
there
um so uh 6f which is on page 85 is our
risk maturity assessment
um for uh
2022-23 uh there's no opinion on this
one it we use a certain methodology that
basically benchmarks you puts you on a
scale and we can compare you to other
councils and on the whole again
um the council's doing well when we
Benchmark against others and has moved
up since our last assessment on on I
think four out of five of the areas the
only one that you haven't moved up on is
risk mitigation but on all the others
you have moved up the scale so good
progress there uh very good to see so in
on the whole we're seeing you know risks
being well recorded they're being
updated they're being reviewed
um you know risk Management's been taken
seriously and it's good to see the areas
that we are drawing attention to is just
making sure you highlight uh your
strategic objectives which perhaps is
showing
um most highest risks of not thinking
achieved and just making sure that's
reported some inconsistency and risk
descriptions and reviews and Reporting
particularly in sort of local Department
level and then going back to this point
about risk mitigation which is you know
what actions have you got in place to
address the risk we think they could be
stronger particularly where you've set a
Target you're away from the target you
need you know you need to have very
clear actions to see how you're going to
get from where you currently are to
where your target score is so those are
things that have been accepted but as I
say on the whole again I would say that
was a positive report and good to see
the progress from last time
and then finally uh just uh 6G which is
the corporate governance report
um so this is given substantial
Assurance on design moderate on control
um so again uh quite a positive report
we're on page 107 uh onwards here
um so a number of strengths around your
corporate governance you know we're
pleased to see your you're intending to
adopt the LGA model on councilor code of
conduct uh your your um you know making
sure that you have decorations of
Interest we've seen that already today
of course
um there's induction mandatory training
for members
um from what we saw uh you know robust
uh debate overview and scrutiny as well
so a number of good things there to
report on
the a couple of areas that we've we've
highlighted one is around the planning
advisory service report about changes
you could make to your planning
Arrangements uh now it's not for us to
say whether that report is right it's
obviously up to members to determine
what sort of system you want
um but from looking at the documentation
of the discussion it was all focused
around one area in that report and the
other areas weren't weren't really
covered or at least we couldn't see the
evidence that they were so you know
we're saying that when you look at a
report like that with lots of
recommendations for improvement just
making sure that that debate covers the
whole uh of that report so I think that
that's that perhaps that discussion is
going to be uh happen again so that
there is that opportunity just to debate
that and secondly was just around
um the training on on scrutiny which was
uh only attended by 48 of members that
was run by LGA so it would be good to
see obviously a higher percentage I know
again there may have been reasons why
members couldn't attend that but you
know we'd like to see that encouraged
and more more people attending that but
those were the only two areas from that
report and I'll stop at this point and
take again any comments or questions
members Mr councilor keys
hey manager I just mentioned it 40 of 48
of um attendance
that's not good is it
this is compulsory training this is on
all aspects no
foreign
committee
well I would have thought it would have
been is that right that's not 48 of
members no no no it is of the committee
yeah thank you Miss Hughes did you want
to speak
uh just to confirm that that one was um
members voted that the overview and
scripment training should be compulsory
for all members but only 48 of members
then attended training
because
anybody else
um cancer flew took place thank you and
I I just really wanted to seek some
advice from Mr Rubens in relation to
page 111
um you know as Auditors that do you
think that this issue should be sent
back to four Council for consideration
um because there seems to be some
aversion towards that
I I would certainly like to see it being
fully considered by members whether that
is full Council or not I mean I'm not
quite clear about the right Forum but we
would definitely like to see it properly
considered by members and as I said
fully documented that all aspects have
been have been properly debated and
considered
so if I could come back chairman then um
I'll uh I'll happily support that Mr
Rubens and bring forward yet another
motion to cancel but I'll do that uh
I'll I'll speak to the the director of
Service delivery before I do that
because it's certainly something that I
would support bearing in mind what's
happened really recently with costs
awarded against this Council thank you
okay
could not report it says that the
current process of the chair
automatically moving the office of
recommendation is that's not the case no
second paragraph
the current process of the J
automatically moving the obviously
recommendation
it's not actually the case at the moment
we don't do that anymore
all right
five pound is it or ten pound members
ten because
um
sorry
the chairman the chairman doesn't
I think it's the Chairman's some
chairmen do and some chairmen don't
because it's councilman and I just
discussed this before
um earlier because yes yes you will
please Council redwoods I think that was
about the only thing from that report we
actually took forward yeah it was the
only thing I can think of
um and the reason being that unlike in
most committees like here we're debating
the officer's report we're in planning
we're debating the application or the
report
so and it does potentially look like
predetermination if you stop if the
chairman starts blocking a
recommendation before you've even
started I know it isn't but so many
people think
but somebody made a proposal before
there was any debate and that's not how
it works but people in general don't
know that so I was very grateful for
that being
um being recommended and that we took it
Forward I thought we all did but perhaps
we don't uh Council Edwards
sorry I I thought that we no longer did
that none of the commit area committees
did that because it's a perception that
the public have that it could be
predetermination so
we're now on Central we don't do that
I don't don't the chairman doesn't
recommend
the officer's recommendation before the
debate
we don't but it does say in here that's
the current case
you put your microphone on please can
you put the microphone on please sorry I
do know the feeling chairman um
but we if you go about far enough first
we didn't
then we did that's right and now we
don't
and for a while it was recommended that
we do that and most of us did I don't
know how happy we were with it but we
did it because we were advised to yeah
um I was greatly relieved not to because
I think members should have a chance to
discuss and ask questions of the
officers and so on so everything's clear
in their mind then hopefully someone
will put a proposal which might or might
not be the officer's recommendation and
we can have a proper debate on what's on
the table
it actually proves that it needs to go
back to council so I think the councilor
fluka's motion may be supported uh
leader
recommendation it does say that a report
recommendation it's time
so it says management response the
governance issues and wider budget
concerns people do an urgent review a
report for Council to take back see
depth GW so nice to talk that to me it
wouldn't be a report going to council I
thought that's what that was meaning
that there's no therefore I could see
the need possibly the motion that
perhaps I'll be absoluted it because to
me that just seems to say what's going
to happen as a result of this okay um I
take on board your comment but Council
fluke did say he was going to speak to
an officer before actually putting the
motion together
um which I thought was absolutely to be
is agreeable really and then I think
it's his the Council of Lucas Choice I'm
a grateful chairman because you've heard
me exactly right thank you
yes I totally agree with you but I'd
like to just clarify actually what
councilor fluka did say
um members anybody else
no okay so I've got to put the
recommendation first members before you
actually agree so the recommendations
are that the committee considers
comments and approves the following the
internal audit progress report
um July 2022 at 6 a little two follow-up
of the recommendations report July 2022
6B little three workforce management May
22 6C
um little four I'll say uh customer
relationship management CRM March 22 6D
5 internal audit report annual report an
annual statement of assurance 21 22 6E
at six risk maturity June 22 6f and
finally seven corporate governance July
22 6G can I take that on mass and have
Ascent members
agreed thank you
excellent
with me
it comes to Rubens I think that's you
finished isn't it
would you like to leave we can just wait
30 seconds if you want to get your
computer and go you're okay okay I know
our meetings are really uh
um
fascinating
um right members moving on to agenda
item seven pound on found on pages 119
to 134 including appendix one uh
appendix one is on pages one two three
two one three four this is the
infrastructure funding statement now
referred to as the ifs the purpose of
the report is to provide members of this
committee with an update on the
monitoring of section 106 planning
obligations and to seek approval of the
modern District infrastructure funding
statements for the financial year
2021-2022. it's in accordance with the
council's legal duties I'm going to hand
over the report to an out of shortland
our lead specialist planning policy and
implementation officer who will present
the report and she's on remotely so good
evening
thank you very much
um this is just an update report really
from December 2021 and it's to bring the
council in line with the end of the
financial year
previously we've always published these
in December but that doesn't really it
doesn't really churn with everything
else that we do because we produce an
authority monetary report at the end of
financial year The Five-Year Supply at
the end of the financial year we monitor
everything financially financially
yearly in this way so this is really
just to bring the
infrastructure funding statement in line
with the end of the financial year as
well so there's not an enormous amount
of change to the report it's just been
updated since it came before you in
December I've changed the layout so it
needs to make it more visually
presentative and I've added an appendix
at the end about County council's spend
and whatever eventually they've got and
how much money they're waiting to
receive so um I have a bit checked with
them but it may not be absolutely 100
accurate but it's what we know and they
said it's okay and
so what we're going to do now from now
on is we will do this roughly at this
time of year instead of December each
year to to line up on the training
processes
thank you I have councilor Fleming
evening and sorry to jump in I thought
central government stipulated end of
December every year is that not correct
what they say is you have to legally
produce it by December you don't have to
so legally you've got to publish by the
end of December but it doesn't matter
when in the year you actually publish
and a lot of councils do like we want to
do which is also the financial year
because that then makes sense because
you're dealing with money and we're
dealing with money
um so no we did we don't have to we
don't have to do it in December that's
not it's not a rule around this specific
procedure okay thank you members would
like to open it up have we got any
questions
uh Council farming did you have another
question
um
leader
thank you
page one three three times
okay so for plenty has been spent on the
following maintenance to two cane
Crossings
um is that across the whole of Walden in
the district
um and are they really meaning 106
funding respect
for maintenance on 2K Crossings in
Northern
but that development aligned with the
things we should be playing commissions
or am I meeting something wrong
um could you help please
um Anne
it's too I think it's in Malden Town
itself I don't think it's across the
district I can check so and then I can
email the office now
attached to a cloning application more
like something to benefit something
within the community but it does say
maintenance to Fan Crossings yes it does
a lot it's those that might be
associated with some development
self-upper way if I don't know because
because
um maintenance seems to be to me
something that was already there
new yeah thank you um councilor Fleming
okay
who was next no nobody else had got a
question I've got a question I think I
raised it at the meeting did you manage
to look at the investment on Burnham
crash Primary School
from Essex
County they haven't come back to me so I
shall email out the odds when I get to
would you please because I I've queried
these figures if that's okay and I've
just declared that's a non-puniary
interest but uh um cancerous keys
County Council presently preparing to
deliver a new Primary School in Malden
haybridge an extension of both the plume
Malden ormiston's Rivers Academy Burnham
they're still waiting for a relevant
triggers how far are we away from these
triggers because these houses are
certainly every time I go down the road
now there's another one seemed to be
there
um do you have that information to hand
um
no no jokes the ones the work the
primary school in Mountain I think that
my I think the fountain is nearly all in
for that one I'll have to check I can
check and get back to you if you could
and then just send it around to all
members I think it'd be really
interesting because
um obviously members are getting queries
in their inboxes about lack of
infrastructure and it'd be nice to
actually just to be able to quantify and
qualify these figures
um Council Fleming
thank you chair um and I just wanted to
ask about the infrastructure funding gap
between what was in the local plan and
and actually what's deliverable are you
comfortable with discussing that now or
would you prefer to circulate to members
after the meeting
okay I just wanted to sort of ballpark
figure
um
there is there's a funding here on the
South Mountain relief road but I can't
tell you exactly what it is because they
they're just the final design for the
road has not been it's not been done yet
once that's done then they'll be able to
cost it out and we'll be able to tell
you the exact figure
um
or
schools I think there is I think we're
okay I don't think there is funding cat
healthy I think where I think we're okay
um they haven't set this funding Gap
they haven't told us there is so I think
we're okay the main the main one is
going to be the relative Road that's
what that's the main one
thank you and thank you members um
councilor Stevens please
thank you chair
um this probably just my understanding
not not following how the report Works
um on page
126 it shows the
um section 106 monies received for 2122
um and they're in three broad categories
affordable housing youth facilities and
a small amount for monitoring of section
106 but then further down on the next
few pages the items listed are nothing
to do with youth or affordable housing
there are things like allotments I
didn't understand why they aren't under
the same categories please thank you
huh
split down into
click down into coax on on our
spreadsheet so a lot let's sort its own
codes so whenever we pull the report out
it will come out as a separate figure so
using facilities is
on lots of funding a lot and it's just
another lot of funding and it's because
when we ask for Section 106s we'll
negotiate those those sums of money
separately to the x amount for youth x
amount for a lot and then it go it drops
into a separate monitoring box so to
speak so we can keep an eye on each
different form of stage 106 payment
question thank you
um yes I mean absolutely it should be
category categorized
um at a quite a granular level but I
just don't understand why the income is
showing that it's mainly for affordable
housing and youth facilities on page 126
and then the next page says that it
wasn't spent on those things it was
spent on other things which I didn't
really get thank you
those separate things
during that Financial year
Mr Leslie
thanks uh it's about the income that
came in in 2122 so that's the income for
the amounts we received in 21 22 but we
were receiving come in years before that
and I think that's what that section on
expenditure in 2122 is saying it's
expenditure on those items but the
income for those items happened in
previous years so it's just a timing
thing
oops
I'm cancer Fleming please
thank you a question for Mr Leslie the
423 423
000 for health is that the sort of
historic figure that has been in our
reserves for some time
thank you
and I think um
uh and maybe uh were able to answer but
um I don't think we've received any
large sums for health recently so that
would have been from historic amounts
and would have largely been in there but
uh just just um can you just confirm
they haven't received that recently
I want to know
we are on one two nine one two nine
oh to help the health
um the health money yeah that's that's
coming over quite a long period but none
of it's expiry doing this due yet
um but we are just quite expend on
health
um in the next 12 to 18 months over page
um
okay okay thank you um councilor fluka
please
thank you it would be nice to see what
the breakdown of of that money is and
and when you say it's historic where
it's actually going because obviously in
southminster we're bringing forward a
new medical center and I know that
there's a lot of money come forward from
various uh pots over the last few years
so it'd be interested to see a breakdown
of that I'm not expecting it now but I
think it would be useful for for
everybody to see it actually is that
possible Anne
can you speak up he wants a breakdown of
the the health funding because obviously
it's his summer if it's historical and
goes back a substantial amount of time
but obviously what cancer fluke was
saying is there a health health Hub in
southminster as well and he'd just
really be interested to see
um where the money how long the money's
been there and where it's going to be
spent I would imagine I don't want to
put words in your mouth if you want to
repeat it yourself please don't no I
mean look the interesting thing is if
this man is if this is Legacy money I
think there's two questions why hasn't
it been spent because you know the
developments that have come forward and
been finished for quite some time you
would have thought that money would have
been spent and gone to the local
surgeries because that's basically what
happens to this
um so I I just think you know I think
it's probably a Mr Leslie question
really because I think in the shed in
the bottom of the garden you'll blow the
dust off the files and you'll you'll
find you'll find these figures and be
able to give us what we want but I think
it'll be very very interesting to see
what it is particularly if it has been
sitting there a long time Mr Leslie
please thank you sir okay in simple
terms it's a question of where did the
funding come from and where is it gone
and then you can do some analysis around
that and essentially so you can see
where's it come from and what they've
been spent on so yeah yeah absolutely
um leader was you about to say that
yeah
but you see a son and then you want to
know that really has been spent locally
and we're exactly so what cattle didn't
say I agree with to see exactly perhaps
where that Health money is within our
district it ties up with the development
that the money has been a fortunate to
because
surgery
coming who do we know that that money
has been spent rapidly and where
yeah I think that's yeah I think that
you can do that can't you Mr Leslie and
Anne
it's historically
break down um
because that's what the legal of section
106 is saying that that's where it has
to be spent
so um
I'll have a look and sort this out for
this yeah it will it would be really
useful I think because we we have had
quite a lot of development in Burnham
and South Minster and I think the
waiting lists have got longer and longer
um Council Fleming
yes thank you I raised it because I
remember this coming up at the PG a
committee oh only 18 months ago
um councilor stilts will probably
remember it and it the point is it
hasn't been spent it's just sitting in
our reserves waiting to be spent to be
fair to the officers I think it's
because
engaging with the uh NHS is not easy
um but I was hoping that sort of
movement could happen on that
so is she we're grateful if we had the
the report then and um you can either
send it out or it can come at the next
PG a as well to be discussed if that's
okay
German we just need to see the
spreadsheet are you sure thanks all
right thank you anybody um councilor um
it's gone now just Stevens I've got it
right all day we've all got that that
problem at the moment
thank you chair
um on page 129 there's a graph showing
the total amount of funding that's been
spent since 1992.
um I'm quite embarrassed surprised that
parking is the biggest expenditure
it do we also have a net figure for that
because I would have thought that
offsetting that huge expenditure would
be income from the parking where the
other items on there probably don't have
an income and I'd hope that when we see
the net figure it so it wouldn't be
greater than affordable housing for
example so could we have the net figures
please thank you
can just go back to the NHS we have six
weekly meetings we're done now and we
have a role reaction log so it's um it's
a much better system of interacting with
them and they're getting updates and
pushing them to to to bring forward the
developments to spend the funding
whereas we didn't we didn't we didn't
have that before so we do what we do now
and then they work rather an activity we
didn't um it was quite difficult to get
hold of them quite obviously explore
doing other things
um
but yeah the Burnham South Minster
um doctor surgeries are moving ahead you
know they are moving your head now so
yeah I could get the net figure for that
that's fine
I like cancer students
okay that's a fluka soy Chen I think
we're sort of drifting slightly and it's
probably going to be my fault but it was
very commendable that we meet with
health but do we meet with education
because I fear that there is uh an
apocalypse about to arrive in in the
South Minster and Burnham cluster of
primary schools I've been doing quite a
lot of work around that with John
whittendale and whoever the minister is
at the moment and there is a serious
issue there and I'm none of us really
seem to know how to highlight it Essex
recognized it but it's all to do with
lag funding and numbers and I actually
was invited to count the pupils in
southminster Primary School the other
day
because they don't the number the roll
number is nowhere near the Essex County
Council roll number and I I really do
believe that this is going to cause a
huge problem with the local development
plan
um I'm going to say something quite soft
you're a man after my own heart I've
been chasing this subject for a long
time and having the school numbers that
I ring the schools at the end of the
year and in July I haven't done it this
year actually so I've forgive me for
that and I've banged this drum people
will know at this Council for ages
because Mr keylock who was at the ldp
said that when we did you know when they
did the forecast they had the table and
they gave the forecast for numbers and
he and the inspector turned around and
said when I said the forecast is
incorrect they had to take the
information from Essex County Council
rather than anybody else
um because they took that as being read
now we all know the difficulties we've
got in schools we know we live in the
wards and we live in the in the district
so yes I totally agree with you Council
fluke and well done yet another voice
trying to actually Rectify this
um leader finally and then I'm going to
move the recommendation
my interest is and it did come up
actually the circuit applications I
remember the meeting very well in the
two self-inter traffic patients all one
night
and the question was asked what is
because the application said that this
primary schools could take the numbers
but it's a cumulative impact that's what
I'm interested in a community impact
when we keep saying why to another so it
might be in the New York collab
application in isolation but I mean just
about how that's worked out generation
born I think there's a 10-year plan
for Education as well so those figures
can't
always they must be moving or more
applications you have in and you must
look to see what your numbers are how do
they assess that to make sure the Cuban
interview impact is covered I'm not
quite clear
um and yes please
you're muted oh you're okay now and now
you're okay
and test the chair wrote this question
in the day actually and uh Paulina we
did have a meeting shortly afterwards
and County and so we asked them
so how they do cumulative impact is they
have their 10-year plan which they may
review every year so when planning
applications come in they look at the
applications against the 10-year plan
so in a way it affects they are taking
cumulative impacts into account because
the 10 near plan takes cumulative impact
over 10 year period in terms of
population growth and I presume that
they will pin that 10-year plan back now
to the
census information that's just been
produced and that's what they should be
doing the next time they update it
margins populations wasn't that far out
really census and we do we meet
education exactly the same way now that
we meet health and we meet highways in
the same way
um as well
okay
um cancer skill stilts yeah just a quick
one like Council of Luca asks for the
breakdown on the health can we have the
same for youth facilities because
on page 29 it says how much we received
for the Youth facilities but when you go
on to page 30 it says we actually spent
nothing on youth facilities
I know yes and
uh would you use facilities has been
delayed because of covert
um there were there were meetings and
things going on and then covert came
along and so we've got to take that back
off
so we'll be picking that up quickly
won't we because I know there's a big
chunk coming to Burnham on Crouch for
the Youth facilities there so that would
be very interesting
Council Fleming
thank you chair and would it be possible
to give a breakdown of where the spend
for the Youth facilities uh is going
whether it's Burnham self-minster or
Malden
um
got that yeah you have good uh because I
know there's an appetite for a skate
park in Malden so I'm just interested to
learn whether there's money there for
that thank you okay members well we've
given that a really good airing I'm
going to close the debate we've gone
back more than once or twice to certain
members so I'd like to propose from the
chair that the following recommendations
that the committee considers the update
of section 106 planning obligations a
little too that the committee approves
the MDC infrastructure funding statement
for the financial year 2021-22 for
publication as set out in appendix one
do I have a seconder councilor Fleming
do we agree by sent
thank you
okay let's move on wait bear with me
members
ah
it's eight
okay moving on then so agenda item eight
equality diversity and inclusion actions
update the annual review found on pages
one three five to one five four
the purpose of the report is to update
the performance governance and audit
committee on the progress towards
achieving the equality diversity and
inclusion EDI objectives set out in the
equality diversity and inclusion policy
please see below objective one we will
identify the ways to improve our
Workforce data collection which we will
which will be used to inform policy
development and Workforce strategy
objective two we will provide learning
opportunities for our Workforce and our
members to develop a wider understanding
of our communities and their and their
diverse needs and objective three as
officers and members we will improve our
knowledge of and our contact with all
communities and ensure that commit
communities can continue to be involved
in decision making processes and I'd
like this report it's going to be
presented by Natasha Brown I think is it
welcome
yeah
yeah so Mr Leslie first and then Natasha
so hold on Natasha thank you thank you
uh the council is committed to being an
inclusive employer and providing
inclusive services to our communities
following the approval of the EDI policy
in June 2021 the focus has been on
delivering the three objectives outlined
in that policy the action plan detailed
in the report at appendix one
covers what has been achieved so far and
those future actions with time scales
recommendation two of the report asked
the committee to consider a
recommendation to council regarding a
change to the Constitution to make the
language gender neutral
if smart stole my thunder I usually do
that after the office is reports Natasha
do you want to say anything or are you
quite happy with what Mr Leslie's done
no
definitely apologize
okay I'll open it up to the members
members
uh Mr councilor Edwards
I just like to make a
observation yeah
of course item 3.5
I in my previous life my professional
life I was a senior manager with a very
large Danish shipping company and I say
large it was 600 people
and I went on many management
chairing courses
the word chairman is not gender it's and
this was put into US quite a lot it
means managing chair is managing the
committee it's not agenda
that was what we were taught at this
very large Danish chicken company and
I've always thought that so that's just
my observation thing thank you members
um cancer Stevens
I think language evolves and a word
that's got man on the end means
something we don't need that bit I know
people used to say oh a chair is a piece
of furniture but I think we've moved on
from that
foreign
with apologies to councilor Stevens I am
not a piece of furniture I am a chairman
I am chairing the meeting and I have to
say we've actually in our efforts to
keep everyone happy which I have more
than willing to do we've reached the
point where we've got a Madam chair now
I ask you really a Madam chair
I thought we were trying to picture into
neutral
if we are can we do it properly
if we agree
I'm only saying if we are can we but I'm
actually more than happy with it the way
it is
well Council Fleming please I disagree I
agree with councilor Stevens I think
that the time is now just to adopt
gender-neutral language I've always used
the word chair right from 2019
um I just for me it's the most
appropriate
okay
uh cancer Thompson
whatever happened to chairperson that
was a thing for a while I think I've
ever been going to change because I'm
not not here particularly but it was a
thing I think the report recommends
chair or chairperson that's the option
Council of Luca thank you chairman look
you know I think generally speaking I
don't have any problems with this at all
but you know I noticed now that when
we're internal emails now they've got
you know they've
got references to what people want to be
called which I find a bit bizarre but
um
think that as far as you know the role
of chairman or
chair person or whatever you know I I'd
like to think it's up to the chairman
what they'd like to be called and and
and and and you know without making it
too cumbersome you know when you do your
Preamble
um maybe you should confirm what you'd
like to be called
um you know I just think it gives it a
bit of uh you know I don't have a
problem with chairman Madam chairman I
always think Madam chairman actually
sounds quite nice and and I think it
also you know it totally recognizes that
you you the person
so uh yeah I'd like to think that the
maybe perhaps the chair of all these
committees would have some kind of their
own input and we don't tired ourselves
down too much but whilst I've got your
attention I I I'd go immediately to
paragraph 3.4 because I know you're as
Keen as I am to support the nighttime
economy
um but I think for you know I think
councilor siddle should be commended for
bringing this forward as as the EDI
member sponsor thank you
and I think I when um got to councilor
white was
um
um puts his other chair of SNR I
actually asked her if she wanted to be
called what she wanted to be called and
I think it's quite nice but anyway we
are where we are I'm going to read oh
yep Mr Leslie
yeah yeah thank you I think the spirit
of this is is to provide Choice
um at the moment it's not prescriptive
it's not saying you have to be you know
that you have to use that terminology I
think 3.5 uh gives that choice and says
you know it's up to individuals so they
want to be addressed as chairman or
chairwoman it's down to them so the
spirit really is to provide that that
choice
um for people
it's a you know point of process I mean
you know we've got a pretty the
recommendation really refers to an
amendment to the Constitution and no
more
so we're really actually talking about
the written word in the Constitution and
it expands out slightly so maybe you
want to make that point clearer when we
go to council to get this approved
because all we'll have is a resolution
so you know I just think maybe put that
in because I think when people when
people read the recommendation to
council they'll think that's hard and
fast but that only refers to the
Constitution and I'm sorry to come back
yeah uh Mr Leslie yeah just to say that
the recommendation I'll take that on
board just to say the recommendation
does does outline to refer to section
3.5 which which has that so
um I don't know if that sort of covers
it if that's all right
no no that's Stephen's last time
changing the subject if I may
um on in appendix one on page 140 so
this isn't about what people are calling
themselves this is about access to us as
a council
um it refers to monitoring Trends and
it's about making phone calls instead of
using the web basically we've still got
black holes in us in our phone system if
you press one for this two for that
three for the other eventually somebody
will say go online goodbye
and we haven't resolved this I I know
now the trick for getting around it but
I get people all the time saying to me
well you can't get through to anyone at
Malden and I have to tell them what the
trick is to do it and that's just nuts
um can we resolve that please I don't
want to be told go online goodbye thank
you I think Mr Holmes could mention this
because something came to us and now
didn't it
wasn't this discussed at us and I
remember banging on about as normal
yeah chairman yes obviously we're
looking at customer strategy and there
are choices in terms of how the council
deals with its customers and what
systems it had but be interested to
perhaps talk to you separately about the
incident you found and we'll certainly
look at it maybe it's full maybe it's
not but I can't comic obviously what on
your experience what I will look there
for you
okay thank you all right thank you
members I'm going to put the
recommendations that Mr Leslie has
already put but I'm going to propose it
the recommendation little one is that
the committee reviews the reports and
notes progress and the EDI action plan
and recommends to council that the
council's Constitution be updated to
reflect gender-neutral terms rather than
him stroke chairman from the options are
set out in section 3.5 of this report
um and member salutations are removed as
standard practice I think that you'll
take on board what council Fergus said
so when it comes to council it will be
clearly explained
refers to section 3.7 the recommendation
yeah you'll just make sure that that's
clear when it goes to the council yes
please thank you um so I would like to
nominate that to recommend that um
councilor let me would you like to
Second me members do we agree by sent
Ence
be noted that I do not Ascent just in
the minutes please
um can that be noted please a burner
councilor Thompson does not agree she's
um to the recommendation
I know
yesterday thank you thank you thank you
very much okay members any of the best
items of business that the chairman
decides are Urgent I have none so
members I'm going to close the meeting
now and I thank you for your
contributions this evening I now draw
the meeting to a close at 8 30.
um as the meeting is now closed members
are advised not to enter into any
further discussion and please leave the
meeting room via the exit door behind
the top table bearing in mind social
distances thank you and Well Done
members thank you good night